good afternoon everyone
i'm here with dr hinshaw
alberta's chief medical officer of
health for a weekly update on covent 19
in the province
it's our first update of the spring
it's a hopeful time as we continue to
return to a more normal life
but we need to acknowledge that coca-19
remains with us and the health system is
still under significant pressure
more workers are returning to in-person
to their workplaces
families are revisiting spring break
traditions and albertans are getting
back to the routines they had
pre-pandemic
there is no question that covid is still
with us but as time passes we continue
to see the impact is less than it has
been in the past
and our health system continues to
recover from the fifth grade
looking at hospitalization numbers today
there are 956 people in hospital with
copen19 including 56 in icu
like most of our numbers
hospitalizations can fluctuate from day
to day but i'm pleased to report that
hospitalizations due to covid continue
to drop slowly but surely
i'm also pleased to report that covet 19
outbreaks and hospitals have fallen
significantly
since the peak in mid-february
at the peak 38 acute care facilities had
active outbreaks and as of monday march
21 only 11 facilities reported active
outbreaks with minimal impact on
patients i know this is a relief to
patients families and staff
and the system is nearly back to normal
surgery volumes approximately 96 percent
of average weekly volume volumes in
pre-pandemic years
our surgical wait list is stable at
around 76
350 this week compared to approximately
78 400 at the beginning of last month
now for context the wait list was 68 000
in february of 2020 before the pandemic
and at its peak
after the fourth wave it was 81 600.
now the current list is too long
we need to get it down and we're working
on doing that
but the reality is
this health system has gone through an
unprecedented global crisis the
equivalent of five winters in the past
two years and the impact on patients has
been much less than it might have been
thanks to our dedication of our health
workers
as a pressure from coverdeses the system
is showing tremendous resilience and
we're pressing ahead on our commitment
to improve access to care including the
alberta surgical initiative
the goal is simple to get the wait list
down and keep it down so that ultimately
we can give every albertan the scheduled
surgery that they need within clinically
acceptable time
this was a big commitment even before
the pandemic
it's a goal that no province has ever
reached coba 19 has stretched out our
timeline but it hasn't changed our
commitment
we're already pressing forward building
on the work that we started before the
pandemic
we're identifying new opportunities and
accelerate the work wherever we can and
we'll have more to say on this in the
coming weeks
in the meantime coven 19 is still with
us dr hinshaw and her team continue to
work with ahs to monitor it to ensure we
can respond to anything the virus may
throw at us so once again i would like
to thank them and their teams and all
healthcare workers for continuing to go
above and beyond to provide quality
compassionate care for albertans so
thank you and i'll now invite dr hinshaw
to make her report
thank you minister and good afternoon
everyone
this is our first week transitioning
from daily to weekly reporting
due to this transition the numbers
shared today include four days friday to
monday
next wednesday and every week going
forward our reporting period will cover
seven days from tuesday to monday of the
following week
as i mentioned last week information
will be shared at weekly media
availabilities and posted
online when you visit the statistics
dashboard at alberta.ca
you may notice that some pages look
different
or that some information is no longer
there
we have consolidated some data to ensure
we continue to provide the most current
and relevant information to albertans
and that it's presented in a
user-friendly way
turning to the numbers
the leading metric that is most useful
at this time is our positivity rate and
between friday and monday this ranged
from 20.6
to 27.1 is an average of 23.5
as the minister mentioned there are
currently 956 people of covid19 in
hospital including 56 in the icu
sadly since friday an average of five
deaths per day related to covid19 have
been reported to alberta health
these individuals were between the ages
of 54 and 94.
this is a reminder of the fact that this
infection is still a significant threat
to many of us our families and our
friends
it's important to take this seriously as
we move into activities we haven't done
for a while
and consider how best to support those
around us to mitigate the risks
my thoughts are with anyone who has
recently lost a loved one whether to
covet or any other cause
we have had many questions from
albertans about the ba2 sub-variant of
omicron that has been in the news
recently and i'd like to share what we
know so far
first it's important to remember that
many viruses constantly change through
mutations this is to be expected
especially with a virus as transmissible
and prevalent as the one that causes
covid19
this is why since the start of the
pandemic we have been actively
monitoring the genetic code of the sars
cov2 virus in the province
this has helped us to understand how the
virus is evolving in our population and
to detect the arrival of variant strains
from outside the province
as we've seen over the last two years
some variants emerge and disappear
without large impacts while others
persist and become dominant like delta
and omicron
currently all covid19 cases identified
through pcr tests are screened for
variants of concern
and our variant screening and sequencing
for genomic surveillance picks up
variants and sub-variants including ba2
as of march 21st approximately 60
percent of positive cases rba2 so it is
now the dominant strain of omicron in
the province
although inherently more transmissible
than ba1
so far there is no evidence of it
causing more severe disease than ba1
based on clinical data
from south africa the united kingdom
denmark and ontario
while this is good news
we only have to look back to the fifth
wave to see that a virus that is more
transmissible can cause a large impact
at a population level
even if the risk of severe outcomes are
the same or lower for individuals
therefore we should expect to see
transmission trending upwards in the
coming weeks
meaning that those at risk of severe
outcomes should revisit their
precautionary measures
and those who have not yet gotten their
booster dose should do so as soon as
possible
this is particularly important for those
who are 65 or older or those who have
medical conditions like copd or diabetes
that put them at higher risk for severe
outcomes
a booster now will provide important
added protection in the coming months
i also want to speak briefly about
fourth doses there have been a lot of
questions about whether we will be
expanding eligibility for fourth doses
to those who have had their third
booster many months ago
we have taken this question to our
alberta advisory committee on
immunization several times
and their advice so far is aligned with
the national advisory committee on
immunization
which is to offer a fourth dose at this
time
only to those with significant
immunocompromising conditions who had a
primary series with three doses
our data from the fifth wave showed that
three doses in other groups
continue to provide a high level of
protection against severe outcomes
there has been much discussion about
data from israel and the u.s on fourth
doses
and while we are watching this closely
it is also important to remember that
vaccine series spacing in canada used a
longer interval between first and second
doses than was used in these other
countries
we now know that the longer interval
provided a higher level of protection
and it is not yet clear how that plays
out over time
i've also heard questions about those
who got astrazeneca vaccine last spring
and then received mrna vaccine
with a final dose more than five months
ago
there are questions about whether this
particular group should get a fourth
dose and this question was also taken to
our advisory committee
at this time the recommendation for this
group remains the same as for others
those who got astrazeneca and then one
or more doses of mrna vaccine more than
five months ago
are not recommended to have additional
doses
if they have already had a total of
three doses of vaccine
we continue to monitor the evidence very
carefully and to listen to the advice of
our provincial and national advisory
committees
we will inform albertans of any changes
to fourth dose recommendations and
eligibility whenever they are made
regardless of what variant or
sub-variant is most prevalent in alberta
we know that we have tools at our
disposal that have served us well over
the past two years
the most important thing each of us can
do to limit the spread of copic 19 is to
get the protection that vaccines offer
if you or someone you know hasn't
received all the doses you're eligible
for yet please do so today
vaccines are widely available across the
province and the majority of locations
are offering walk-up appointments for
adults and youth
more information is available online at
the alberta vaccine booking system and
the blue cross list
of locations with vaccines
another critical step we all need to
take is to stay home when we have
symptoms
with that i would like to remind
albertans that there is a substantial
supply of free rapid tests available at
pharmacies across the province
just check the alberta blue cross
website to see which locations near you
have them in stock
and pick up several boxes to have them
on hand in case someone in your
household feels sick
remember that with rapid tests if you
are feeling sick it is important to take
two tests 24 hours apart if the first
one is negative it's also important to
stay home and away from others until you
are feeling better even if both tests
are negative
i know we all wish we could forget about
covid19
completely but unfortunately it will be
with us for a long time to come
we can support each other to take steps
to balance the risk in our own lives
remembering that our actions also have
far-reaching impacts on those we don't
know
thank you and we're happy to take
questions
thanks dr hinshaw and minister no one in
the room here with us today uh but a
couple of waiting on the phone so we'll
go to the first a caller please
mark gillian ptv
hi there uh this is the question for mr
copping i'm related to kobe but uh we're
just talking about dental care in the
province we're wondering what does the
province think about expanding to
universal dental care
starting with use as announced by the
ndp liberals federally how would it be
ruled out at a provincial level
well thanks for the question mark
you know i will be first of all we'll be
interested to see what the federal
government will be putting forward in
terms of the plan and then we'll take a
very close look at it
we do provide some support
for dental
for
low-income seniors and low-income
individuals at this point in time
so
there is a program we have in place uh
so we'll we'll look to see what the the
federal government will uh will put on
the table but i guess one other comment
that i'd like to make this goes back
both with the the dental plan and the
uh the pharmacy plan
is that you know our preference would be
is having the
federal government be a
partner in funding providing the funding
so we don't have duplication of the
programs and we can work together to uh
to fill the gaps
thanks minister mark you have a
follow-up
that's good thank you very much all
right thanks mark i think we have just
one other caller so we'll go to the next
and last one please
jared come again global news
hi this question is
um so i'm wondering how many cases that
do you believe there are in alberta
previously during the height of omicron
wave you said we were about catching one
in ten with testing so limited what do
you estimate the virus numbers you truly
are here in the province
it's difficult to give you a specific
number we have
worked through the serology results that
we got from the samples taken in late
december and early january
and so comparing those serology samples
with the case numbers prior to
sort of mid to late december which is
the
um
what would have been captured by the the
timing of when that serology was taken
that did validate that estimate of
approximately 1 in 10 at that point in
time it's likely that that ratio has
changed given that it was after that
late december time frame that we changed
our eligibility for pcr testing so it
will quite certainly be
a greater gap than just one in 10 but
what that estimate is is very difficult
to say we anticipate that we will have
our updated serology data
in about a month to be able to
understand what that actual number of
cases is but again
it would be greater than uh that ratio
of one in ten
thanks dr insha sarah follow-up question
yeah please um i'm also wondering when
it comes to the
covet drug that uh
could take i think it was i believe that
they were unvaccinated i'm wondering if
we like what kind of um what we've seen
with that so far and if you know how
many people have actually taken it at
this point
i'd have to get back to you about the
number of people who've taken the
medication
what
we are doing is we're continually
looking at our own data and
looking at the evidence to determine
who's most likely to benefit from the
medication the evidence that
was used to
license the medication is really focused
on those who
have no vaccine
given that they are at the highest risk
of severe outcomes
in addition to that people who have been
vaccinated but have severe immune
compromising conditions are also
eligible for treatment independent of
how many doses of vaccine they may have
received and there is ongoing discussion
about any additional eligibility
criteria that we may look at in the
future
as emerging evidence
arises but again
right now it's being offered to those at
the highest risk for where there is
specific evidence and we can follow up
afterwards with the number of how many
people have accessed treatment i should
just make a note that there are two
different treatments that are available
one is sutrovomab which is a an antibody
treatment and another is paxlovid which
is the
medication and so part of the assessment
process is to determine which of those
medications those who are eligible would
likely benefit from the most
and would encourage anyone who is at
risk of severe outcomes and who test
positive for cova to access the
information available on the alberta
health services website about how to
access the early treatment program
thanks dr henshaw so we'll wrap it there
thanks folks i will ask the department
of communications staff that's helping
health to get back to you sarah with the
answer to your question and we'll see
you back here next week for another
update thanks all